liberal bail reform policies wreaking
havoc all across the country and the
radical district attorneys and
politicians who helped put in place
those dangerous reforms don't think
there's anything wrong with what's going
on take la's top prosecutor george
gascon he's getting called out for his
silence amid rampant theft in his city
the zero bail policy he loves just freed
14 looting suspects
law enforcement officials in california
are fed up
los angeles is like
like the movie purge but instead of 24
hours commit your crime they have 365
days to go out and commit their crimes
and that's how it is right now we're
catching the criminals and the problem
is we're catching them over and over
again and they're being released very
quickly without bail and they're not
staying in prison so we just continue to
deal with the same same people again and
again gets even more absurd in my
hometown of philly city just had one of
the deadliest years ever a radical d.a
larry krasner doesn't see a problem
there is not
a big spike in crime that is not true
there is also not a big spike in violent
crime we don't have a crisis of
lawlessness we don't have a crisis of
crime we don't have a crisis of violence
okay
and over in chicago there's been a
frenzy of crazy smash and grabs mayor
lori lightfoot has the audacity to blame
the retailers
some of the retailers downtown and
michigan avenue i will tell you i'm
disappointed that they're not doing more
to take safety
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
institute
plans like having security officers in
their stores making sure um that they've
got cameras that are actually
operational
all right tyrus and philly
on the street they call the d.a uncle
larry because they know if they get hit
with something he's going to let him
right out
people know what the policies are in
these cities and they're just taking
advantage of it i'm sorry my my little
ears i know they're cauliflowered for
defending my title this weekend but did
she just say the retailers were asking
for it yeah yeah she did they shouldn't
decorate their windows that way or put
new things
where are we to where this is the point
i don't even know i'm in shock she with
a straight face and almost a giggle
so they were asking for in what walk of
life can you ever say that
if i if my child was like
little t why did you steal the cookie
well it was asking for it i would
give him a spanking and send him a
therapist because he thinks cookies talk
to him this is crazy
we're seeing
and there's no way to fix this because
they've gone so hard on our boys and
women in blue the police department in
california my hometown
they've either retired or they've moved
somewhere else so even if you put let's
say they put five million dollars to get
the police to force back to crack down
on this you're looking at at least 18
months to get a new police officer
trained and get out there
and the criminals know this so you
arrest the guy
you can't even go to the press
conference and they're already out but
there's nothing to see here and all the
things that would you call uncle
uncle larry uncle larry yes all those
things are down because homicides weigh
up so yes attempted murder done
lowest ever how's homicide it's a little
up was 130 it's like unbelievable yeah
and it's the same people it's it's not
it's not like thousands and thousands of
people it's the same couple hundred guys
doing the same crimes and just getting
let back out and you hear this from
police that are able to speak on camera
or in the newspapers that basically
they're saying it's demoralizing for
them they go out they do all this hard
work but they know they're going to be
back on the street the next day and then
especially if they commit additional
crimes what lori lightfoot just said is
like what alec baldwin said last week
when he said that the cinematographer
whom he killed
was to blame for the direction i mean do
you not want to have retail stores on
madison avenue in chicago is that or
michigan avenue excuse me chicago i know
it's michigan avenue um it's a it's a
beautiful street and it's been that's a
hallmark of a place for chicago it's a
wonderful place to to live and it can be
a great place to visit but if you're
worried as an employee about going to
work because you're afraid for your life
or if you're a customer and you think
maybe it's just better not to go into
the store maybe i'll just buy it online
they're going to drive more and more
people out and then that also hurts the
small business people
because they have those shops that they
want right next to the fancy ones so
that they can get the foot traffic the
only foot traffic is a career criminal
you're not going to sell anything
so lori has always been pushing the
crime on the south side you know as long
as it happens on the south side
everything's fine you know
now it's up in the nice retail areas
right in the miracle mile in chicago and
now she's saying it's your fault
it's your fault bloomingdale's louis
vuitton
why do you look at me i'm looking at you
harold
tell laurie what to do it's a compliment
it's a compliment believe it or not
louis vuitton is a nice story
i would say this you're right
the uh everything that's been said is
right i think the most alarming thing i
think you're going to say well here no
for a city official
uh is what tyrex what you just said
about the time it's going to take if we
decide to fully fund the police which we
should as a nation
if you were mayor right now of a big
city you'd have to look at three or four
things on the table one how do you if
you did have a bell reform package that
passed over the last year how do you
reform that bail reform package because
we're letting out violent offenders it's
not working like we wanted we wanted to
try to protect non-violent offenders
what we're doing is we are enabling
violent offenders to get out two we have
a mental health crisis in the country we
we've talked about this around this
table and mayors and others if i were
the head of the mayor's association i'd
be appealing to this administration and
to my congressman and senator and
governor to help us help us figure out
how we have some sort of comprehensive
way to deal with this mental health
crisis on our streets as well and then
finally you even with the 18-month
challenge we have maybe we asked some
retired officers to come back i know
katie you talked about many are moving
outside of some of these big cities what
can we do to incent some of these
trained officers to come back until
we're able to get those who wish to go
into this profession a noble and
honorable profession to do that and
finally mayors have got to try to help
rebuild this trust between communities
and police officers when i was growing
up i wanted to be a police officer when
you were a kid you talked about wanting
to be a police officer i realized i was
not strong enough or fast enough to do
it yeah that's what i wanted to do you
now probably don't have as many kids
saying that certainly as many diverse
kids in the diversity in this nation you
have to have
police officers that come from different
backgrounds so i get her frustration but
she was wrong and said that the mayor
yeah and i hope if she has a chance to
correct that she will but we've got to
look at this holistically and i just
don't think that we are wrap it up katie
well the leftist philosophy of crime is
on full display they don't think that
this is a problem because they believe
in blowing up the system tearing it down
and replacing it with chaos and that's
exactly what they're doing now none of
this is happening in a vacuum it's
happening in blue cities well what else
do a lot of these blue cities have very
strict gun control so when you look
around at what's happening when you had
this palisades holiday party for example
it's not just happening at stores and
you have people criminals with guns
coming into a holiday party and robbing
everybody at the holiday party we have
the physical therapy office in beverly
hills
all these guys come in with guns rob the
doctor take his watch rob all the people
in in the physical therapy office
there's no deterrence no the cops aren't
going to be there they're not afraid of
getting arrested because they'll be
released and they also know that
everybody there has been put in a
position where they are not allowed to
own a firearm without jumping through a
number of hoops and they know that there
will be no response because there can't
be or people will be vilified by the
very people like mary mayor lori
lightfoot and as we've seen when people
have defended themselves before and for
the mayor of chicago to say that the
stores need to hire more security
okay well what do you want them to do
then or will the security guards be
allowed to be armed probably not uh do
you want store owners then to arm
themselves and do what kyle rittenhouse
did which was to defend the property of
a car lot owner are you allowed to do
that now so this whole philosophy of
what they think it's not just one thing
it's not just the bad da's the defund
the police it's also defunding people's
ability to defend themselves and then
blaming them for it and then daring to
you know and then completely criticizing
them and vilifying them and destroying
their lives in the media should they
decide to take on these criminals that
the politicians and the da's have
allowed to run rampant not just at the
stores but in people's communities
robbed at physical therapy yeah you
can't even use harsh language because
you'll offend somebody and get cancelled
is nothing sacred
you're getting your sciatica stretched
out watch guys come back
to the one time you could do a lighter
injury sciatica is kind of a first it's
an old man injury tyrus
what's a cool injury learning how to
walk again from saving kittens and
burning you out of the tree well
everybody out there watching sciatica so
you're welcome hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else